once again spoiler warning gonna talk
about spoilers for jokers so if you
haven't seen Joker probably shouldn't
watch this also I feel like this video
more than a spoiler talk is really
useless if you haven't seen Joker so you
should probably watch Joker first if I'm
going to have a past I prefer to be
multiple choice that phrase that comment
is in every review of Joker on the
internet period sometimes it's there
with no context whatsoever
other times the context is that's why I
don't want to watch Joker's because his
backstory should be multiple choice I
always took that phrase as well the
other movies and the other comic books
they also exist so they're all just as
relevant but good news the movie Joker
itself is multiple choice which is why I
wanted to make this video let's talk
about the multiple choices also in
addition to the also can we all stop
using that image and thumbnails [ __ ]
movie just came out that's a big moment
in the movie you stopped putting that in
the thumbnails but after seeing the
movie twice it's like you know my review
my spoiler the review is like alright I
saw the movie once taking it at face
value this is paying attention to some
of the hidden meanings out there and
I've seen a lot of chatter about
possible interpretations of Joker
I'm by no means some authority figure on
it but having thoughts so why not it's
like a Joker weekends everyday Joker
video so I'm just gonna talk about my
thoughts as to some of these
interpretations and theories the funny
thing about them is there's no way to
prove or disprove them it's just you
have some circumstantial evidence go
where it takes you go where you want it
to take you that's kind of fun so let's
talk about it what are the
interpretations of this movie is that it
was just all in his head he just
imagined all of it at the very end when
he's in Arkham he laughed he's like I
just thought of a joke the joke being
the entire movie we saw I don't like
living in a world where the entire movie
just didn't happen that's it that's
that's all I got I don't have any
evidence for or against just in my own
personal head can and I like the events
to have happened I don't want it all to
be imaginary then on the other hand
there's a thought that alright it's not
something he imagined while he was in
Arkham at the end it's something he was
remembering when he was in Arkham at the
end which that doesn't change the
logistics of the movie though I feel
like that's a plus B or B plus a either
we saw everything happened and then at
the end he's in Arkham and that's that
or he's in Arkham remembering everything
that happens but it still happened with
a second scenario his mental state his
memory his interpretation isn't as it's
not as on point
is reliable so there's that variance of
people get to fudge with things and that
makes it fun I'm totally down with the
entire movie of Joker being him
remembering the events as he's you know
dressed in white in the white room you
know in Arkham there was a scene where
his therapist says earlier on in the
movie that he was committed to the
mental hospital it shows him banging his
head against the door that is absolutely
how we looked at the end of the movie I
don't know if I'm supposed to break the
fourth wall to interpret it it just be
as easy as Todd Phillips it's like all
right we're filming this scene by the
way what we're filming this scene at the
end of the movie you mind we just film
you banging your head against the wall I
think we're gonna use this somewhere he
does look a little different in that
scene than he does in the rest of the
movie I don't know if it was a reshoot
that they did it was purposely done
because it's supposed to take place
sometime later but there are things in
this movie that give credence to the
possibility that it is a memory and not
everything that happened happened the
way he remembers this supposedly penny
Fleck worked for Thomas Wayne 30 years
ago adopted a kid 30 years ago how old
was the kid we don't know if the kid is
actually Thomas Wayne's kid the kid
would be 30
Arthur Fleck looks older than 30 but
that could give way to the theory that
everything we just saw is him
remembering the past
Arthur Fleck much older than 30 could be
remembering his past and he's basically
projecting himself in these events as
the age he is when he's remembering them
don't like you ever have a dream or a
memory of you and Christmas when you
were a kid but the you in that dream or
memory is you now I've had that happen
so that's how I'm gonna see it if I'm
gonna see it like that
granted he does imagine himself on the
Maury show so if it's a memory within a
memory that we're getting into inception
but early on the movie actually gives
you a hint that things you're about to
see might not actually be how it
happened is when he's spinning the sign
the kids jump in beat him up smash the
sign over his face and his boss is like
come on you stole the sign right both
times I watched this movie I was like
okay I'm gonna look for that sign in his
apartment I couldn't find it not in the
two viewings I've had but a truck in for
a third that I feel like that sign is
The Smoking Gun if you see that sign
behind his couch or anywhere in his
apartment that's the smoking gun now you
know like okay we just can't trust
anything we see here granted the Zazi
beats girlfriend thing in which she
wasn't actually hanging out with him
that that is essentially that that's
just for that one scene there's a lot
more that makes you go well did that
happen that way like he got a gun from
his colleague and he was like oh by the
way
his gun and colleagues like stop talking
out of your ass now that's what someone
would say if someone pointed a finger
someone else like no I got the gun from
him or maybe he didn't actually get the
gun from him maybe he got the gun
somewhere else maybe he just went to the
store bought a gun I like that thought I
think that's cool the biggest one for me
and I noticed this is my second time
watching this movie is when he meets
Thomas Wayne he sneaks into this theater
he confronts Thomas Wayne Thomas Wayne's
a dick to him but this is when you find
out all penny might have been crazy but
then Thomas Wayne slugs Arthur and then
walks away and Arthur leans up against
the sink and the next shot is him
leaning up against his counter in his
apartment in the same position that's
actually one scene where it's like did
that confrontation happen the way it
shot leaves it open to look I don't know
you decide you don't know if what you
just saw took place in his head and
that's when he goes over to the fridge
and pulls everything out of the fridge
and goes into the fridge so it's
possible that his own imagination is
driving him nuts which brings us to the
hole is Thomas Wayne his father is he
his father is he not yeah - either the
movie gives you circumstantial evidence
at best the best evidence in the movie
is the paperwork saying well penny fleck
was crazy
and tied her kid to a radiator while her
boyfriend beat him up true Thomas Wayne
might have had that forged we went
arthur's reading Penny's file it shows
her and she's like he was a little boy
you're like something happened there but
it does pan over and it shows him in the
corners kind of scowling at her like
that implying that this whole scenario
you're seeing is him imagining it does
it happen that way like if she's
mentally ill and she passed that on to
her kid
genetically well then he is her kid
which would imply Thomas Wayne is his
father and dudes 30 I guess or he was
adopted the abuse caused mental illness
and Thomas Wayne was right about that
he's actually not the father yeah I've
had a lot of people in the comment
session like didn't you see the picture
of penny and on the back is there
something like you have a pretty smile
TW Thomas Wayne right so I was like okay
there's one thing to do match up the
handwriting and the best picture of the
handwriting I could get because you just
got to find a letter right so T and
Thomas that letter that she wanted to
send out to Thomas Wayne the T is like
that really big loop T whereas on the
back of the picture it's a T like that
so I was like okay penny did not write
the message on the back
of the picture because she's crazy or
anything that was someone else who wrote
it that's not exactly a smoking gun for
me you have a cute smile
that's a flirty message it doesn't mean
oh by the way thanks for the sex that
wasn't written on there when I first saw
it I kind of took it I was like all
right he was probably flirting with this
chick and then turns out she's crazy and
like was stage-five clinger know and you
know she lost her mind cuz you know
she's already lost her mind or Thomas
Wayne had sex with her and Arthur Fleck
is his kid you don't really know there's
no way to actually get to the bottom of
that mystery the most important thing
about Arthur seeing that picture and
crumpling it up is the fact that he
crumples it up that really shows right
there he's like oh another piece to the
puzzle don't care
throws it away so he just he
legitimately doesn't give a [ __ ] anymore
that's my biggest takeaway with that
scene anyway also maybe he died in the
car wreck and now he's in purgatory I've
heard that one don't think so either cuz
at that point you don't actually you
know get Joker it's not a joke or origin
story really
and also any movie that ever had someone
get into a car wreck and live you can
again go alright
they died in there and the rest of the
movies actually it didn't happen it's
just in their head if their synapses are
firing off before they die that's not a
specifically Joker thing you can do that
with a lot of things is Thomas Wayne his
father I don't know one way or another
there's no way to prove it one way or
the other but in my own head Canon I
assume that Thomas Wayne is not his
father his mom was a very sick lady who
knows maybe next year when I'm thinking
about it maybe I'll be like you know
what this year for 2020 I'm going to
assume Thomas Wayne is his father but
I'm gonna interpret this movie I prefer
it to be multiple choice is the movie a
memory of his as he's in Arkham at the
very end of the movie
quite possibly actually is the movie a
memory of his the reason he was laughing
about Bruce Wayne's parents dying
because of Batman caught me I know
Batman's identity and that's really
funny his parents died because of me you
wouldn't get it that's kind of fun to
think about too maybe the events in this
phase in his life happened exactly how
we saw them maybe they didn't I think
that's Todd Phillips doing his job I
think Todd Phillips is doing his job
very well just like giving us a movie
that's a cohesive movie we're watching
it go down then after the movie you
think about it and you have doubts about
certain things and if you keep pulling
on that thread you get to the point
where you're like I don't know what's
real but that's the feeling he has
that's a feeling you're supposed to feel
because he feels that I enjoy the
this movie's definitely open to
interpretation this movie is definitely
multiple choice all of which flies in
the face of people who reviewed the
movie and said well there's nothing here
except surface-level yeah I disagree all
right so Joker's theories theories of
your interpretation of this movie what
do you think happened you think it's
straightforward which it's kind of how I
saw the movie at first I still actually
do I'm like 90% straightforward there
are a couple of moments in here though
where I'm like did that happen so what
do you think do you think it didn't
happen and he imagined it do you think
it's from his memory do you think it
happened exactly how we saw it you think
it was 90% what we saw but there's some
fudge or somewhere in there because it
does show that yes schizophrenia because
of that reveal we now have to doubt a
little more than that once it's not like
it's isolated to that one incident
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]